ma google compact utis incredibile
episodio di stia provando ragazzi come
la settimana scorsa alla scalata al
champion mamma mia che sole offrono
quindi sarò un po più siti di queste
partite perché mi devo concentrare se
non c'è più non ci arrivo neanche
dopodomani bello non ti preoccupare sono
io che sono spinte porta magari ancora
bravo pesca ma anche con la fare gol
ecco come entrato in questa ballata
l'altro ci siamo abbiamo ci sono
scontrati a caso cioè non so come vada
li guarda come dire veramente era un
millimetro dall'essere top 10 chilometri
orari
c'è gol assurdo abbiamo due partite da
diamanti ai tre tratto quando tre occhio
e non so se riesco a tornare
bene pupazzo bella fratè avvocati un bel
controllo 15 22 è il momento di entra in
partita anche con i gol da parte mia
perché sono anche quello un bel cross ma
ci sei
eccolo lì il missile bianco può arrivare
può arrivare fuori non è pari all anno è
arrivato però il controllo della madonna
giornata nessuno è stato bravissimo
perché ho detto provati l'acqua anche se
effettivamente andrea polenta ma è
bastata è bastato il tiro per entrare
incredibile ok ok bellissimo
peccato per il tiro avevo paura di
scritti dalla troppo forte che uscisse
però ancora base non perdona 42 proprio
a loro va da iunco mai ancora yankov ai
franco vai banco bella non male non male
non male normale anche se non ci sei
ero troppo storto non potevo dire ok le
52 sorrento da parte degli avversari
perché adesso arriverà sicuro in 3 2 1 e
la vittoria va al fare una bella partita
visto che dobbiamo lanciare in champion
my brother all right mai in personal
sassi morto ok si mort bravo mai si mort
se non la tocca vi segnalo non farti
segnare però è il tuo momento di vedere
che premia sei perfetto bayern i party
io non posso perché il turbo life reso
tu gli vai tu vai fratello bel tiro a
seiano così con simon 29 in partenza
bravissimo secondo me buoni propositi
per questa partita è questa bambina
ancora direttamente centro di parte
occhio fratello dove sei ha mandato palo
pochi a pochi o 3 si porta bravo hanno
fatto che occhio bella la parata
tranquillo adesso riparto con turbo e
non sono andato forse doveva dare però
non fa niente perché lui non se
l'aspettava quindi vado lietamente
sull'altro turbo e poi li do fastidio
vediamo che sono una proposta facciamo
tutto senza non ce l'aveva vero evo lei
di raja bell controllo dello zio però
non basta perché il favi punisce niente
non son riuscito a prender lavorando
però poi parlato il fratello vice il
turbo ok davanti all'altro
bellissimo bellissimo non è mai by brown
2 a 0 ma anche a tre minuti let's go
questa anche sembra buona indici
superiori per ora siamo sempre contro la
matita e prima che arriva a champion
lega però nel mentre stiamo formando
partiti con stesse partite per arrivare
cento in più facile ma se come ci arriva
anche con surfer nega occhio occhio che
rimbalza in mezzo frate l'occhio che qua
poiché si cavalca bravo che si doveva
andare avanti
occhio che questi che fanno casino tira
di razzino la bella tega ambiente cosa
succede cosa succede ma cosa così
succede
ma cosa che vorrei ma cos'è e cosa ha
fatto
ma cos'è era non ho capito niente ma
l'importante che abbiamo segnato abbiamo
vinto proprio vittoria così facciamo
l'ultimo ragazzi facciamo vedere
soltanto gli highlights di sta partita
l'ho mai giacimenti sono gli highlight
l'ex
[Musica]
un nome che fa bella
[Applauso]
la ragazza
la vacca
bene
la fonte
[Musica]
poi come potreste surrender e così
eccolo bene 40 35 secondi rimanenti e la
partita è il official concluso deve
avere mai vittorietti e così proprio
tattiche speriamo che vi sia piaciuto
più di oggi ragazzi road to champion
vediamo cosa succede ragazzi per me è
molto complicato e tra questi ragazzi
bilancio è un bel mi piace anche ai
social che ogni notizia se non siete a
quesiti iscrivetevi e non scegliamo come
sempre al prossimo vino e da ragazzi
[Musica]